[Musique]
oui oui la porte d'entrée ce jeu si la
jce to say we bâle 3-2 d'accord alors je
vais faire vite parce que je suis en
retard pour mon vol est le système de
sécurité est au bout du couloir la
chambre d'amis est prête ciao
et bon veulent
quoi pour moi connectez vous à une
personne voyante sur demande pour une
assistance mutuelle dans un appel vidéo
le plafond
lumineux fenêtre du sol au plafond
avenue multi perdu merci
site est désactivé
si l'heure ça on a un problème je crois
qu'il y a quelqu'un fera pour moi salut
comment je peux vous aider fiat et
chantant la mission vous êtes surpris je
crois qu'ils cherchent
je suis à la porte
il faut l'éliminer tout de suite elle a
vu nos visages non j'ai rien vu
qu'est ce qui se passe ici
moi
qu'est ce que je dois faire
au
hockey l'erreur ma chérie